[Musique]
place à la jeunesse c'est le mot d'ordre
de l'édition 2022 du prix indienne
océanie originalité de cette quatrième
édition le concours littéraire jusqu'à
maintenant ouvert à tous est lancé en
direction des groupes de jeunes âgés de
12 à 15 ans c'est ce mercredi 29 juin
qu'a été donné le coup d'envoi de la
quatrième édition lors d'une visio
conférence de presse par béatrice
sigismeau vice président en charge de la
culture et des laâyoune hommes
marimoutou secrétaire général de la coi
la commission de l'océan indien les
cheveux même pendant les vacances on les
appelle à pouvoir s'inscrire peut-être à
travers des activités vacances portés
par des associations ou même à la
rentrée avec les épaules les collèges
pouvoir s'inscrire dans ce projet c'est
un projet d'envergure
internationale et on incite tous les
jeunes réunionnais et participer un
appel à écriture 100% numérique qui
invite les jeunes à produire un conte ou
une nouvelle sur un thème spécifique
le thème de cette année est vraiment eu
très ouverts ça c'est de terre mère ciel
et feu donc ce sont des éléments est
source de couleurs qui vaut vraiment
travailler nos jeunes qui ont envie de
participer à ce concours est de faire
marcher leur imagination
l'appel à écriture est ouvert du 30 juin
au 15 octobre 2022 à destination des
résidents des comores de la réunion de
madagascar de maurice et des seychelles
toutes les conditions sont à retrouver
sur le site du département
[Musique]